Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW,
unsere kleine Welt, mein Name ist Tim Pritlov und es ist Freitag und das heißt auf diesem Kanal
Corona Weekly, der wöchentliche Blick auf Zahlen, Daten, Nachrichten und was uns sonst noch so in die Quere kommt
das mache ich wie immer mit Pavel, hallo Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Genau und jetzt haben wir hier wieder ein paar Stunden an den Artikeln herumgezuppelt, die uns hier vorgeworfen werden vom Internet,
und den ganzen Zahlen, die uns vorgeworfen werden vom RKI zum Fraß vorgeworfen werden. Kamen sie denn dieses Mal.
Zuverlässig, so wie man sich das wünscht.
Na ja, geht so. Es gab dann irgendwie einen vermeintlichen Glitsch am Anfang der Woche, der hatte aber irgendwie nur damit.
Äh zu tun, dass jetzt die Veröffentlichungszeitpunkte vom Land Berlin und vom RKI ein bisschen anders sind und das viel halt zusammen mit dann auch irgendwie ab.
Absurd niedrigen Zahlen für Berlin fürs Wochenende,
für das für das letzte, sodass ich da erstmal dachte, okay, da ist was kaputt, aber es war nichts Spezielles kaputt, nur das Übliche kaputt
also das wie am Wochenende halt keine Ahnung,
nur einen zehntel so viel Fälle eingegeben werden zum Teil oder oder bearbeitet äh werden oder teilweise einige Gesundheitsämter gar nicht. Ich glaube, die haben Gesundheitsämter, habe ich das Gefühl, haben von der Pandemie auch die Schnauze voll und haben keinen Bock.
Äh da irgendwie ähm Wochenende rumzusitzen. Ja.
Sich ja irgendwie Panimi zu bekämpfen. Also am Wochenende ist halt Panimiebekämpfung nur im Notbetrieb.
Ja lässt sich denn trotzdem was rauslesen für diese Woche.
Ja, lässt sich ja immer was rauslesen, so ist nicht, dass äh ja die Zahlen jetzt belanglos wären.
Und gut was ich rauslesen lässt für Deutschland ist, dass die Zahlen bisher weiter nach unten gehen. Das ist
glaube ich ja noch erfreulich, wobei äh wenn man ganz genau hinguckt,
sieht man, dass der berühmte RWT,
ganz, ganz langsam wieder im sieben Tage Schnitt nach oben.
Aber das ist ähm ja wirklich sehr, sehr langsam.
Also wir liegen jetzt so bei null Komma neun eins Grade, beziehungsweise je nach je nach Interpulations äh Methode, so null Komma neun eins null Komma neun.
Bis null Komma neun vier irgendwo in der in der Gegend befinden wir uns und wie sagt mit einem seit.
Nur einer Woche ungefähr mit einem ganz, ganz leichten, minimalen Anstieg, aber es geht
halt nach wie vor, ja, also hält sich der R-Wert noch,
bundesweit und äh dementsprechend ja gehen die Zahlen runter. Also wir haben jetzt na ja noch nicht ganz.
Mitte vom Berg erreicht, wenn man sich jetzt die letzte Welle ähm also die die jetzt se.
Oktober läuft, die im Oktober angelaufen ist. Da sind wir.
Jetzt wieder äh den Berg halb runter, noch nicht ganz halb,
runter. Ja bei mit einem Durchschnitt von ungefähr zwölftausend infizierten pro Tag,
und in der Spitze nur waren wir mit dem sieben.
Tagedurchschnitt bei sechsundzwanzigtausend ja also wie gesagt ungefähr.
Etwas mehr als die als die Hälfte sind wir wieder vom Berg runter und wenn das so weiter.
In ja je nach also bundesweit.
Ungefähr drei Wochen würde ich sagen einigen Bundesländern werden wir schon in zwei Wochen dann unter den berühmten fünfzig ähm.
Ja äh was natürlich immer noch viel zu früh zum äh Öffnen wäre, die fünfzig. Also eigentlich wenn man unter zehn kommen oder wenigstens unter zwanzig,
Eigentlich wenn man auf null kommen äh unter eins, sage ich mal. Aber ähm,
ja bei den jetzt ähm Neuinfektionen pro hunderttausend pro Woche, falls nicht.
Also ich meine, wenn der RWT hat jetzt ist im Vergleich zur letzten Woche nicht weiter gesungen
Ja, also so im im Rahmen des äh der Ungenauigkeiten kann man, glaube ich, sagen, er ist im Wesentlichen konstant, so eben um
um null Komma neun, das ist ja an sich schon mal eine ganz gute Nachricht, dass er überhaupt unter eins ist, aber wir kennen ja das Lied, wir bräuch.
Eigentlich ein sehr steilen Abfall und den sehen wir halt nach wie vor nicht. Das heißt, es wird irgendwie nicht besser und wir
sind ja nun auch in der Situation, dass es durchaus sein kann, dass uns jetzt demnächst die die bösen Mutationen äh in die Quere kommen,
Man sieht es jetzt in verschiedenen Landkreisen, die Berichte äh darüber, dass die gefunden werden, also das Ding ist jetzt in Deutschland, ne, dass äh alle Diskussionen über man muss die Verbreitung stoppen,
durch irgendwelche Maßnahmen, also wenn jemals irgendwelche Maßnahmen in dieser Hinsicht beschlossen wurden, dann dann haben sie nichts gebracht.
Ja, dass es hier einfach ins Land eingetragen worden. Es ist in den verschiedensten Landkreisen, also es davon auszugehen, dass wenn sich diese Variante oder
diese Varianten gegenüber den Standard Corona Saasgruf zwei, Virus durchsetzen, dann dann wird das halt auch statt stattfinden. So, also es ist halt einfach,
an der Stelle auch wieder mal gescheitert. Das waren glaube ich mal so so klar sagen, also da wir sind nicht in der Lage, uns gegen,
Varianteneintragung zu schützen. Schlichtweil wir uns einfach nicht ausreichend gegen Eintragung von außen überhaupt schützen. Das heißt äh auch alle.
Gewinne der nächsten Wochen könnten jetzt relativ leicht wieder dahin gehen in dem Moment wo diese Varianten dominant werden,
glaube ich ist auch schon die ersten Leute, die sich mal genauer anschauen, hm, was eigentlich mit diesen Landkreisen passiert, wo diese Mutation zumindest schon mal nachgewiesen wurden.
Was ich da jetzt gesehen habe, würde ich jetzt mal unter äh.
Inconclusive abbuchen, also es ist irgendwie noch so ein bisschen unklar, äh ob da jetzt eigentlich wirklich was passiert oder nicht
Das werden wir sicherlich nochmal im Auge behalten müssen. Aber ich habe so ein bisschen meine Zweifel, dass wir wirklich in zwei oder drei Wochen bei fünfzig ankommen, weil wir einfach.
Trends haben, so und äh es sich derzeit noch nicht so richtig absehen lässt, wie sich das entwickelt.
Ja? Also ja, was die Situation mit den neuen Viren oder den neuen.
Varianten angeht.
Und strains. Äh ich äh suchte nach äh sagen nach den neuen Linien äh äh,
Ja die sind durch
Also es gab jetzt auch erste Zahlen so aus Köln beispielsweise und äh heute hat er wohl auch das RKI ein paar Zahlen vorgestellt. Mh,
kann sagen größenordnungsmäßig äh,
fünf bis fünfzehn Prozent ungefähr der bei den aktuellen Fällen dürften auf das Konto neuer,
ja gefährlicherer oder infektiöser Motationen gehen und bei der Zahl und bei den Verdoppelungsraten, also wir haben,
in England gesehen, dass innerhalb von zwei Monaten dort die Zahlen von zwei Prozent auf siebzig Prozent hochgegangen sind, also der der Anteil der äh,
halt B eins eins sieben äh basierten.
Viren ja hat sich innerhalb von äh zwei Monaten, wie gesagt, auf siebzig Prozent hochgearbeitet und wir können davon ausgehen, dass es,
bei uns auch nicht anders sein wird und dass wir aber äh äh dort schon relativ weit sind, also äh in.
Spätestens drei Wochen dürfte sich der Anteil deutlich beim Ehrwerk spürbar machen, da werden wir nämlich bei dreißig, vierzig Prozent neue Varianten sein, da da merkt man das schon
und spätestens in sechs Wochen ähm ist das die dominierende Variante wahrscheinlich deutlich
früher. Äh es gibt halt so ein paar Unsicherheiten bei.
Bei den Zahlen aber größtenordnungsmäßig haben wir in vier bis sechs Wochen haben die neuen äh Mutationen ja,
über fünfzig Prozent und werden halt irgendwie, weiß nicht, sechzig, siebzig, achtzig Prozent der Infektionen ausmachen.
Ja und dann wird sie halt entscheidend sein, wie weit wir runtergekommen sind, ne, weil wenn man jetzt einfach dieses Infektionsgeschehen nicht insgesamt in den Griff kriegen, dann dann äh wird sich das natürlich dann enorm beschleunigen können dadurch.
Ja. Also im Grunde genommen haben wir jetzt nicht mehr wirklich,
viel Zeit, wo die Zahlen tatsächlich nach unten gehen ohne dass wir noch weiter verschärfen,
Also wenn alles so bleibt, wie es jetzt ist, wenn die Zahl der Kontakte so bleibt, wie sie jetzt ist, wird eben allein aufgrund der neuen Varianten.
R Wert in spätestens drei Wochen über eins gestiegen sein selbst im Jahr.
Genauso taff durchhalten und nichts lockern und auch äh ja,
niemand Corona müde wird und äh einfach Maßnahmen ignoriert und so, wenn selbst wenn das alles gegeben wäre, was es wahrscheinlich nicht ist, äh können wir davon ausgehen, dass in drei Wochen,
die Zahlen einfach aufgrund der.
Zu zahlreichen Kontakte, äh die wir immer noch haben in der Bevölkerung äh nach oben gehen, die mehr aus sich,
überlegen so zehn Leute infizieren halt immer noch neun weitere und,
hatte auch mal so eine kleine Umfrage gemacht auf auf Twitter, nicht repräsentativ, wie viel Kontakte die Leute denn haben und ob das zumindest größenordnungsmäßig,
mit dem übereinstimmt, was so beispielsweise aus England gemeldet wurde.
Also es gab halt mittlerweile in England mehrere Briefings über die sogenannten Variance of Konzern ähm äh zu denen eben auch B eins eins sieben gehört und.
Unter anderem erfasst man dann die Kontakte aller
die positiv getestet werden, wie das eigentlich bei uns die Gesundheitsämter auch machen sollten, aber halt nicht irgendwie nicht mitkommen und bei uns werden bisher die Zahlen so auch nicht veröffentlicht, aber was man dort eben an Statistiken hat.
Ist, äh, wie viele.
Kontakte, ähm die Leute hatten, die infiziert waren und wie viele dieser Kontakte dann anschließend sich infiziert haben.
Diese Zahlen kennt man für verschiedene Altersgruppen und für die verschiedenen Virusvarianten und da sieht es eben so aus, dass ja zwischen.
Zehnundzwanzig Prozent grob der Kontakte.
Die genannt wurden äh dann anschließend ebenfalls sich infiziert hatten. Ja ähm.
Und.
Daraus kann man aber natürlich auch auf die Aggressivität schließen, weil die noch äh unterschieden haben zwischen ähm eben ja.
Der Anzahl der Kontakte, die durch Corona Classic infiziert wurden und die Zahl der äh Kontakte, die durch die.
Die neuen Varianten infiziert wurden und daher hat man auch die Zahlen für die erhöhte Aggressivität, wenn man festgestellt hat, dass von.
Den erfassten Kontakten inzwischen äh zwanzig.
Fünfzig, teilweise sechzig Prozent mehr ähm infiziert worden. Äh so.
Als bei den alten Varianten. So, ja und.
Daher auch der höhere Ehrwert von null Komma vier bis null Komma fünf und die Rechnung ist halt ganz einfach, wenn wir jetzt im Moment null neun haben, ähm kann man sich überlegen bei zehn Prozent neuer.
Varianten übern äh Daumen würde sich.
R ungefähr, wenn man sagt, bei hundert Prozent wäre Ehre um null Komma fünf erhöht, wenn man sagen bei zehn Prozent äh erhöhen die neuen Varianten dann den Airwert um null Komma null fünf.
Will sagen wahrscheinlich, wenn die neuen Varianten nicht bereits.
Auf dem Vormarsch wären hätten wir, weiß ich nicht, theoretisch null Komma null fünf in der Praxis wahrscheinlich null Komma null drei oder null in der Gegend halt weniger an R. Das heißt.
Dass wahrscheinlich die Maßnahmenverschärfungen, die letzten, die stattgefunden haben.
Äh deswegen zu keinem Rückgang geführt haben, weil äh allein schon die neuen.
Varianten auf dem Vormarsch, da sind neuen Varianten dürften eben bisher so bundesweit,
ja nicht ganz null Komma null fünf. Ähm auf den Ehrwert drauf bringen, weil's eher kann sich natürlich dann überlegen,
relativ einfach ausrechnen, wenn das so weitergeht, wenn wir fünfzig Prozent erreicht haben, dann ist null Komma zwei fünf auf äh auf den RW und ja
bei.
Neunzig Prozent eben entsprechend null Komma vier fünf, also sprich wenn wir jetzt für den alten Virus irgendwie eine eine null Komma
Fünfundsiebzig erreichen würden, dann sind wir mit dem neuen Virus halt deutlich übereinstimmen wir bei eins Komma eins eins Komma zwei.
Gleicher Kontaktanzahl.
Und von null Komma sieben fünf für den alten Virus äh sind wir auch weit entfernt. Das haben wir wie schon hier mehrfach betont. Bisher überhaupt erst ein einziges Mal sehr kurze Zeit geschafft.
Die null Komma neun, die wir derzeit haben, die legen nicht gerade nahe, dass wir jetzt irgendwie nächste Woche auf einmal dann den totalen Durchbruch haben und auf einmal sehr viel äh niedrigere Infektionszahlen sehen. Also.
Das ist so ein bisschen das Problem an was auch noch mit dazu kommt ist natürlich äh ich weiß nicht wie du es wahrgenommen hast, aber ich lese jetzt auch schon wieder so von den ersten Leuten, die über irgendwelche Lockerungen nachdenken.
Ne? Im politischen Raum und da äh zieht's bei mir immer so richtig in der Seite, weil wir ja hier,
mehrfach herausgearbeitet haben, wenn irgendwas wirklich dazu beiträgt eine Änderung der ähm Reaktion der Bevölkerung herbeizuführen, dann,
ist es die Diskussion darüber und in dem Moment, wo man darüber diskutiert, zu lockern, dann machen sich alle gleich wieder ganz locker und dann ist es alles gar nicht so schlimm und dann äh,
haben wir den Salat.
Er. Ja, also ich hatte da auch oft für da einige,
etwas äh ja erboste Kommentare so ähm nach dem Motto aha jetzt kann man ja noch nicht mal mehr über angeblich über Lockerungen äh diskutieren und ja äh.
Leider ist es so, in dem Moment äh je lauter die Lockerungsdiskussion ähm so umso mehr Leute lockern einfach von sich aus.
Die warten das halt dann gar nicht ab, sondern ah okay äh ist jetzt lang genug gewesen. Ich.
Die Lockerungsdiskussion macht locker. Das ist eigentlich so.
Lockerungsdiskussion macht locker, ja? Das ist ich mein das ist natürlich so Politik und Demokratie theoretisch und so. Ähm es ist natürlich ein krasses Problem, dass man im Grunde genommen
ja aus Infektionsschutzgründen eigentlich Maulkorb verhängen müsste und eigentlich auch Medienzensur betreiben müsste. Also
Zensur wäre tatsächlich auch ja ein Beitrag zum Infektionsschutz.
Ist bloß jetzt nicht unbedingt das, was wir vorschlagen, um das gleich mal klarzustellen.
Ja, ist ja ist nicht das, was wir vorschlagen, aber äh so.
Hinweis auch insbesondere heute.
Ja, was ist, dass der Verband der Immobilienwirtschaft, die jetzt heute wieder in der Presse waren mit
Lockerungsforderungen nach dem Motto, ist alles zu teuer und
wir müssen irgendwie wieder aufmachen, weil die Geschäfte können halt keine Miete zahlen und ähm Leute müssen wieder in den Büros arbeiten, sonst kündigen die Leute hier Büros und die Immobilienpreise sinken und überhaupt alles ganz
äh ja gleichzeitig gibt's ganz klar andere Stimmen, die sagen.
Ja eigentlich bräuchten wir insbesondere für die Wirtschaft härtere,
Maßnahmen, weil mittlerweile sind wir im Privatbereich na ja also,
im Privatbereich zumindest gegen die Einschränkungen, viel, viel weiter und viele Dinge, die im beruflichen Kontext.
Möglich sind, sind im privaten Kontext halt.
Komplett ja verboten von mein, du darfst nach wie vor Dienstreisen machen, Leute dürfen ähm ja in Innenräumen äh zusammen.
Arbeiten teilweise unter Bedingungen, die definitiv auch Übertragungen.
Ermöglichen äh so dann teilweise Notbetrieb in Schulen und Kindergärten ähm.
Wo ja bis äh also in vielen Fällen fünfzig Prozent teilweise sechzig, siebzig Prozent habe ich gehört, der Schüler halt,
in der Notbetreuung sich sich befinden, was ja jetzt auch nicht der Sinn unbedingt von ähm ja Schulschließungen äh ist. Äh und dann ja die Flugzeuge fliegen.
Die Bahnfahnen der ÖPNV fährt äh und äh ja die Wirtschaft läuft irgendwie zu neunzig, fünfundneunzig Prozent ja.
Ähm wird gearbeitet so.
Und das alles sind Dinge, wenn wir uns die einfach mal für zwei oder drei Wochen gespart hätten.
Dann ja das stünden wir jetzt ganz woanders und wenn wir das.
Dezember oder eigentlich im November praktiziert hätten, dann äh ja wäre das ganz,
alles ganz anders gelaufen, um sich auch vergewährt vergegenwärtigen, dass in den letzten sechs Wochen genauso viele Leute an Corona gestorben sind,
wie.
In dem ganzen Zeitraum davor. Also wie über ja was zehn, elf Monate.
So und.
Ja, das sieht nicht gut aus. Aber ähm noch so noch die nächsten, ich hoffe ein, zwei, drei Wochen können wir uns über.
Fallende Zahlen in Deutschland freuen, Verhalten freuen.
Verhalten freuen.
Jetzt haben wir den fünften Februar äh zwanzig einundzwanzig, habe ich äh eingangs mal wieder vergessen zu erwähnen. Das bedeutet ähm.
Man kann eigentlich davon ausgehen, dass wir so in diesem Februar sollte sich eigentlich an dieser Situation zumindest eigentlich nichts lockern.
Ich hab so ein bisschen meine Zweifel, dass das stattfinden wird, aber bis Ende Februar müsse
ähm der Spaß eigentlich mindestens so weitergehen wie er derzeit ist. Das ist nicht schön, aber das ist nun mal die Konsequenz daraus, dass man eben vorher nicht bereit war zu handeln. Und jetzt zieht sich das halt alles ewig in die Länge und wird irgendwie auch keiner so richtig glücklich damit.
Und nach wie vor asozial der Toten.
Auch jetzt rückläufig seit zweieinhalb Wochen ungefähr.
Ja, da wird die Kurve tendenziell ja deutlich flacher, also sp.
Hatten wir ein bisschen Rückgang in der ersten.
Woche und äh jetzt in der letzten Woche so äh ist das fast schon wieder äh äh auf.
Einer Ebene verharrt und das bei einer.
Ja noch viel zu hohen äh äh Zahl von ungefähr siebenhundert Toten pro Tag im Mittel.
Und ja also da hoffe ich, dass das jetzt.
Auch den Infektionszahlen folgen wird, dass wir da genauso einen Rückgang haben werden, aber bisher haben wir, während wir bei den bei der Zahl der täglichen Neuinfektionen.
'ne Halbierung hinbekommen haben gegenüber Weihnachten so wo der Piek war.
Ja, sind wir bei den Toten, wo der.
Wo Mitte Januar war, sind wir jetzt gerade mal vielleicht Fünftel runter, so zwanzig Prozent.
Und Tendenz aber.
Ja es bleibt, es scheint sich eher zu stabilisieren. Hoffenem viel zu hohem Niveau schon wieder.
Wenn man und wenn man mal so in die Fläche gucken jetzt nochmal ein bisschen bisschen näher in die in die Bundesländer rein, haben wir jetzt seit Wochen.
Ja so die die östlichen Bundesländer äh immer oben gehabt. Jetzt hat sich langsam Bremen auf Platz vier dazwischen geschoben.
Hamburg hat sich auch von Mecklenburg-Vorpommern gesetzt, also ist äh Ost und West durchmischt sich gerade wieder.
Und äh Sachsen ist auch in der Risikotabelle äh nur noch auf Platz vier, jetzt ist im Moment.
Ja Thüringen, Saarland, Sachsen-Anhalt.
Sind halt vorne auf den ersten drei Plätzen, dann kommen Sachsen, Bremen, Brandenburg, Hamburg, Mecklenburg-Vorpommern und Bayern.
Steht in der Summe auch noch ganz okay.
Ja, mit einem R-Wert von null Komma neun vier, aber.
Guckt man dann auf die absoluten Top dreißig Landkreise gerade dann.
Sind das äh alles etwas beunruhigender aus, weil mittlerweile auf den ersten sechs.
Plätzen, was die Landkreise anbetrifft, sind es alles bayerische Landkreise, Hof, Tischenreuth, Wundsiedel, nochmal Hof, Ansbach und Weiden.
Dass es da wo gerade auch die höchsten Anstiege zu verzeichnen sind. Gleichzeitig mit Institen von noch zweihundert bis dreihundert, also in,
galoppiert's gerade, dann kommt dreimal Thüringen, nämlich Eichsfeld, Schmalkalden, Meiningen und Hildburghausen.
Ja, also Landkreise, die man schon mal gehört hat, dann auch noch, ja, Suhl und Saale-Orla-Kreis und Altenburger Land, also ja, Thüringen und Bayern ähm.
Sag mal belegen.
Fast alleine, die die ersten zwanzig Plätze kommt irgendwie dann einmal Brandenburg und einmal Saarland hängen dann noch dazwischen, aber ja das ist die Situation.
Wenn man so ins ins Land guckt, kurvet freie Landkreise, in dem Sinne, das in den letzten sieben Tagen.
Keine Fälle aufgetreten sind, haben wir nicht äh im Sommer hatten wir ähm nach der ersten.
Welle äh immerhin ja fast einem Viertel der Landkreise waren Kobit frei nach der Definition.
Also wir haben auch richtig sehe, haben wir auch kein Landkreis mit Institzen unter zwanzig bisher.
Also auch das, ja und auch schon immer richtig sagtest hm.
Berlin als in Berlin.
Die Institutionen über die fünfzig gegangen sind, war Berlin ja der krasse solchen äh Herd so mit.
Ja äh diskutierten Beschränkungen und und so Hotspot und äh ja und wir haben im Grunde genommen aber eigentlich.
Nach früherer Definition fast nur Hotspots in Deutschland.
Deutschland ist ein einziger Hotspot sozusagen, ja.
RA doch mhm ja.
Ich habe gerade mal geschaut, was denn.
Nee, nee, ich ans Tabellenende hatte ich halt äh gerade nochmal geguckt und da ist äh das niedersächsische Emden.
Scheint irgendwie am grade am besten da zu stehen mit siebzehn Komma neun äh Institanz.
Ja und was auch auf jeden Fall äh zu erwähnen ist, ist Rostock, eine Stadt, die sich äh auch schon die ganze Zeit extrem gut hält, so,
Bei Emden könnte man halt immer noch argumentieren, dass das halt doch ein relativ dünn besiedelter Bereich ist, ja? Friesland und so, da äh.
Kann's halt auch mal schief gehen und da ist es ja auch schief gegangen. Da gab's ja auch irgendwie gleich zu Beginn der ganzen Sache, da.
Restaurant in Sinne, Vorfälle äh et cetera, aber Rostock fährt schon die ganze Zeit eine relativ äh klare Politik.
Und äh das zeigt, dass man halt auch in größeren Städten dichterer Besiedlung durchaus auch was reißen kann, wenn man eben die richtigen Maßnahmen ergreift.
Rostock auf der einen Seite und Görlitz auf der anderen Seite nebeneinander hält, sieht man einfach, dass.
Dass man einfach auch eine ganze Menge falsch machen kann. Beziehungsweise eben auch eine ganze Menge richtig machen kann.
Ja, interessanterweise bei Rostock äh ist auch äh die Institution im Landkreis Rostock sind äh höher als die im Stadtkreis Rostock.
Das heißt äh.
Bevölkerungsdichte ist jetzt nicht notwendigerweise äh des ausschlagende Merkmal, sondern ich glaube, es ist das Verhalten der Menschen, was äh.
Den Ausschlag gibt und nicht wie dicht sie aufeinander äh wohnen jetzt, also hm sofern.
Nicht zu viele Leute, also für alle die Haushalte natürlich nicht nicht zu groß äh sind. Dem Moment, wo du halt ja.
Zehn Leute pro Haushalt hättest, wäre das glaube ich auch anders aussehen, aber so grundsätzlich jetzt macht der Abstand der Häuser oder Wohnungen äh macht jetzt nicht so viel äh aus, äh wie.
Ja ob die Leute gewillt sind, aufzupassen oder nicht.
Und ja, vielleicht wenn wir die Zahlen jetzt äh einfach nochmal zu zu Ende durchmachen, weil ja jetzt ja schon viele Verwandte Aspekte gestreift, aber äh ein.
Dingen, was wir auch jedes Mal tun, ist ein Blick auf die Testzahlen zu werfen, nämlich,
zu sehen, inwieweit denn jetzt,
was an Zahlen gemeldet wird auch mit der Infektionsentwicklung übereinstimmen, weil wir wissen ja auch wenn man die Zahl der Tests verdoppelt dann.
Findet man auch mehr Fälle, jetzt nicht doppelt so viele, aber es steigt und wenn man die Zahl der Tests halbiert, findet man,
ja zwar nicht die Hälfte, aber auf jeden Fall weniger positive Fälle, insofern muss man halt die Testzahlen immer daneben halten, beziehungsweise die positiven Quote ist immer ein sehr guter Indikator, der dann.
Ja
Nicht völlig unabhängig, aber zumindest deutlich unabhängiger ist von anderen Schwankungen und die positiv Quote,
ist auch wieder weiter gesunken. So und zwar ja.
Deutlich von einer Woche auf die andere ähm also äh wir haben.
Wieder zwölf, dreizehn Prozent weniger äh positive Tests jetzt in der in der vierten Kalenderwoche.
Und haben aber fast die gleiche Zahl der Tests beziehungsweise eins Komma vier Prozent mehr Tests gemacht und,
äh
Ja Zahl der positiven Tests und dreizehn Prozent zurückgegangen und die positiven Quote um vierzehn Prozent und liegt jetzt bei acht Komma fünf drei.
Dass äh ja ist auch definitiv noch.
Ein zu hoher Wert, um über Lockerung nachzudenken. Also die WHO äh sagt halt solange deine positiven Rate über fünf Prozent liegt äh.
Vergiss Lockerung.
Perspektive zu setzen, acht Komma fünf drei
positiven Quote, das ist 'ne Zahl, die haben wir zuletzt gesehen, zu Beginn des Lokdownlights. Anfang November, das war in etwa die größten Ordnung, die wir damals hatten
Also als die Kurve richtig anstieg und äh im Prinzip die zweite Welle so richtig begonnen hat.
Ja und,
ungefähr der Höhepunkt auch der ersten Welle, also in KW vierzehn hatten wir halt in der ersten Welle neun Komma null drei Prozent als,
maximale positive Quote und da sind wir also also wir sind jetzt auf dem Höhepunkt.
Welle. Ah ja, genau.
Das ist ein guter Vergleich. Weil die erste Welle ist von den von den reinen Infektionszahlen äh schwer zu messen gewesen, weil damals gab's halt einfach noch nicht so viel Tests, also da ist ungefähr so ein Drittel der Test durchgeführt worden. Da war ja auch noch alles neu,
wenn wir uns jetzt mal wirklich nur an dieser positiven Quote orientieren, was glaube ich eine ganz gute Zahl ist.
Dann äh ja dann dann gibt das glaube ich ungefähr so ein Gefühl dafür, ne? Also ob die Infektionszahlen damals gestimmt haben, die wir da hatten oder nicht, wenn man sich jetzt deine Grafik äh anschaut, ist ja unser derzeitiger Berg,
ähm noch noch noch deutlich höher als wir das eben in der ersten Welle hatten, aber vielleicht kann man's jetzt hier einfach mal hochrechnen und ich würde das jetzt mal so deuten als
Vermutlich hatten wir in der ersten Welle doppelt so viel infizierter, als wir wirklich gemessen haben.
Und wir befinden uns halt jetzt quasi dort.
Dass äh ja spricht natürlich dann auch nochmal für deine These, so dass wir so in in zwei bis drei Wochen, wenn's gut läuft, äh wieder auf fünfzig runterkommen könnten.
Vorbehalten ist natürlich der äh ganzen Eingang schon erwähnten äh Dinge hier mit Botationen und so weiter, was uns jetzt noch äh in die Quere kommen kann.
Aber ich glaube das ist, das ist schon mal eine ganz gute Verordnung, ne? Also äh wenn ihr auf die Situation jetzt äh blickt, so, dann dann kann man's vielleicht einfach mal zusammenfassen,
Wir sind jetzt ungefähr auf dem Höhepunkt der ersten Welle.
Mit unserer zweiten Welle und ähm die Anstrengung, die wir damals gemacht haben, um davon runterzukommen, die bräuchten wir im Prinzip jetzt auch. Machen wir aber nicht. Mehr Büros sind geöffnet,
und natürlich ist die Maßnahme Müdigkeit.
Die Kraft äh natürlich um sich, dafür habe ich auch Verständnis, aber jetzt gerade, wer genau der richtige Zeitpunkt, dann nochmal die Zähne zusammenzubeißen.
Also eigentlich wär's.
Ja vielleicht auch politisch und psychologisch äh sinnvoll gewesen äh sagen erstmal einen vorläufigen Endspurt äh,
auszurufen, das heißt, dass man dann, dass man jetzt nochmal.
Den Leuten die Dringlichkeit vermittelt und sagt, okay, wissen wir, sind jetzt alle müde, aber wir machen jetzt die nächsten,
zwei oder drei Wochen machen wir nochmal richtig alles dicht,
um ähm ja äh wieder auf Zahlen zu kommen, wo unsere Gesundheitsämter auch wieder äh.
Eine nennenswerten Beitrag zur Eindämmung leisten können, weil im Moment ist das in vielen Bereichen schlichtweg nicht so, im Moment läuft in vielen Bereichen achtzig, neunzig Prozent,
der Infektion weitgehend am Gesundheitsamt vorbei, da wir.
Glaube ich ja entweder wird vieles gar nicht erfasst oder dann äh werden halt positive Tests erfasst, aber so die Umstände der Infektion, wann und wie sich die Leute infiziert haben und
und so oder dann
teilweise zeitnah alle Kontakte. Ich meine, es sind halt dann, weiß ich nicht, fünf, zehn, zwanzig Kontakte pro Fall, die dann auch kontaktiert und gegebenenfalls in Quarantäne
geschickt werden müssen und da es nach wie vor so, dass auch viele Leute,
Quarantäneanordnung entweder gar nicht kriegen oder erst erhalten, wenn ja das alles schon wochen vorbei ist und halt klar ist, dass sie sich definitiv nicht angesteckt haben.
Ja.
Ich würde sogar sagen, also bei der wie sich das alles jetzt so entfaltet hat und und was wir so beobachtet haben, was alles nicht abgefragt wird, was äh wie sehr man auch diesem diesem Virus immer äh hinterherläuft, zwangsläufig.
Damit da auch wirklich was Produktives bei rauskommen kann.
Ich denke dieser Blick auch, also ich habe auch irgend so eine Diskussion verfolgt worden äh irgendjemand meinte so ja.
Sie hätte ja gelesen, eine Frau meinte da ist so, dass die Gesundheitsämter so ab fünfzig nicht mehr mitkommen, ja dann müssen wir doch die,
Gesundheitsämter da mit mehr Personal ausstatten, damit die mit mehr Infektionen klarkommen. Und das ist einfach die vollkommen falsche Perspektive auf das Problem, ja? Also so weil die das sind jetzt einfach,
Die Gesundheitsämter, die sind so gerade in so einem Modus, dass sie einfach so ein bisschen blinde Kuh mit mit Fliegenpatsche äh spielen
Ja, die können irgendwie links und rechts versuchen, irgendwo draufzuhauen, aber im Prinzip befinden die sich gerade in so einem Bienenschwarm und haben überhaupt gar keine Chance. Da äh in irgendeiner Form produktiv hinterherzukommen. Dafür ist so ein Gesundheitsamt nicht gemacht
zu einem Gesundheitsamt ist dafür gemacht, dass wenn man eine Infektion aufkommen sieht aus einer niedrigen.
Institz heraus, dass man dann eben mit diesen Mitteln versucht, das,
anfangen im Griff zu halten. Aber wenn's dann halt erstmal so weit sich verbreitet hat, wie wir das jetzt hier gesehen haben, dann helfen halt auch einfach die Gesundheitsämter nicht mehr. Also da da müssten wir ganz andere Strukturen haben,
müssten wir irgendwie Kontaktverfolgung im industriellen Maßstab betreiben und dafür sind wir überhaupt nicht gewappnet und das das funktioniert halt auch einfach so nicht.
Also Infektionszahlen müssen runter, runter, runter.
Definitiv und eigentlich wie gesagt so eine ja wäre jetzt so eine Endspurt Quarantäne ähm oder ja,
Endspurt lockdown, wie man's immer nennen wird, wäre eigentlich.
Vor dem Hintergrund der neuen Varianten, genau das, was man jetzt haben wollte, weil dann könnt man nämlich auch einigermaßen,
Absehen äh jetzt ähm wie die Zahlen nach unten gehen und was eben auch.
Ein sehr schönes nochmal, was man ja auch immer wieder dazu sagen sollte ist, dass.
Alleine Reduktion der Kontakte um zehn oder zwanzig Prozent.
Wenn ich irgendwie zehn Leute im Schnitt treffe, sagen wir mal so pro Woche, wenn ich dann äh stattdessen nur acht Leute treffen würde, dann.
Hätte das extreme Auswirkungen wie schnell die Infektion zurückgeht und mal der der Unterschied halt jetzt zwischen.
Ja
Alleinen bei einem, bei einem R von null acht ist es, also ich sehe äh halb würde sich äh alle drei Wochen.
Ungefähr die die Zahlen halbieren bei einem R von null sieben gesagt, was wir leider nie erreicht haben, würden sich die Zahlen jede Woche halbieren.
Ja äh und ähm ja, das bei durch
sag mal zehn Prozent oder fünfzehn Prozent weniger Leute treffen
im Schnitt. Aber offenbar kriegen wir selbst das nicht nicht hin. Stattdessen treffen wir eben so viele Leute, dass trotzdem jeder.
Dann null Komma neun andere bisher anstehen. Es ist nach wie vor zu viele Kontakte und.
Dass,
im im Endeffekt der Pfad, den ich jetzt sehe, der wahrscheinlichste Pfad, wie es laufen wird, ist, dass es halt jetzt,
noch äh ein, zwei, drei Wochen ungefähr die Zahlen sinken werden.
In der Größenordnung dann äh werden sie eine Zeit lang eher waagerecht verlaufen und dann wahrscheinlich äh äh deutlich abheben insbesondere, wenn.
Dann äh Maßnahmen gelockert werden, dann können wir uns wahrscheinlich eher auf so ein Tschechienszenario.
Einstellen, dass.
Innerhalb von drei, vier Wochen äh wir dann äh wieder Zahlen erreichen werden oder auf einem Pfad sind, der uns wahrscheinlich nochmal eine dritte Welle beschert.
Die Größenordnungsmäßig der zweiten äh entspricht nur, dass wir dann.
Eben die ansteckenden Viren haben, das heißt, dass wir dann wahrscheinlich wieder äh April und Mai,
wieder in einem harten Logdown verbringen werden und zwar wahrscheinlich in einem der härter ist, als das, was wir im Moment haben.
Dass es leider ähm sagen der Pfad, auf dem wir sind mit nur ein paar Wochen dazwischen, äh wo.
Ja äh dann vielleicht die Schulen.
Fühlt.
Offen haben werden und äh ich weiß nicht, welche Lockerung sonst noch äh dann im Gespräch sind, ob dann irgendwie mehr Geschäfte auch wieder aufmachen.
Schwer zu sagen, aber.
Das wird alles dann nur von kurzer Dauer bleiben so, weil wir wissen in dem Moment wohnenswert gelockert wird, schießen die Zahlen wieder nach oben.
Also Ostern wird alles kaputt machen können sozusagen.
Weil sie vorher, also wir machen im im Grunde genommen, machen wir es jetzt gerade kaputt, also im Moment legen wir jetzt gerade schon äh wieder den
den Grundstein, äh, wenn man so äh für die dritte Welle, in dem wir einfach immer noch nicht schnell genug reduzieren.
Ja oder äh es ist so, wenn man's ausrechnet, dann.
Breiten sich die neuen Varianten nicht nur relativ aus, also nicht nur deren Prozentsatz nimmt zu, sondern auch in absoluten Zahlen,
werden es mehr, das heißt, wenn man jetzt sagen Corona alt rausnehmen würde, dann steigen.
Infektionen bereits oder wenn man jetzt die neuen.
Muttertion quasi als neue Krankheit oder neue Infektion betrachtet, dann äh bekämpfen wir im Moment gerade nur die alte Infektion, aber die neue breitet sich äh.
Ja, ich will nicht sagen, nicht ungehemmt, die breitet sich aus, gehemmt zwar, aber sie breitet sich aus.
Auf jeden Fall mit einem Röser eins. Ja, das ist aber eine eine interessante Perspektive da drauf, ne. Vielleicht mal das, ich meine, das ist natürlich jetzt etwas schwierig zu machen, weil wir da einfach nicht genug Sequenzierungs
Daten haben, aber keine Ahnung, vielleicht konsolidieren sich ja die Hochrechnungen da und dann wäre es vielleicht mal sogar ganz interessant, dass einfach gegeneinander
stellen und zu sagen so hier ist quasi gerade die pandemische Entwicklung mit äh mit Covit Classic.
Und hier ist äh die pandemische Entwicklung mit mit Kowit äh Nova und.
Alte Problem kriegen wir langsam im Griff, aber es wird jetzt gerade durch das neue Problem ersetzt. Das vielleicht eine ganz interessante Perspektive, aber ich habe.
Habe Zweifel, dass wir da die richtigen Daten dafür bekommen werden. Um das wirklich richtig ausrechnen zu können.
Ja ich mein das Positive ist, dass wir sehen können, dass auch UK.
Oder andere Länder, wo jetzt B eins eins sieben.
Lange schon ach siebzig, achtzig Prozent ausmacht, dass die es ja gerade auch hinkriegen.
Ihre Zahlen nach unten zu bringen mit einem Lokdown, der sich eigentlich von dem unseren nur in ja eigentlich nur graduell unterscheiden,
so, was man äh sagen, was äh.
Also in England, so wie ich das, wie ich das verstanden habe, ähm waren dort in dem vier Stufenplan in der höchsten Alarmstufe auch keine Schulschließung vorgesehen. Deswegen fahren sie jetzt,
eben ja Level vier and hands in vielen Bereichen.
Wo eben Schulschließungen dazu kommen, aber was dieser Level vier auch immer wohl beinhaltet ist,
zum Beispiel auch Privatbesuche in fremden Haushalten komplett verboten sind. Während bei uns ist ja so ist, dass sie zumindest ähm.
Ja äh irgendwie austrifft, diem gut aus triffigen Grund kannst du auch in England äh jemand anderen äh besuchen, aber von der Formulierung,
ist es so, dass du zumindest wenn du jemanden,
bei dir zu Hause einlädst aus dem anderen Haushalt jetzt erstmal nicht unbedingt gegen ein Gesetz verstößt während es in England erstmal grundsätzlich so ist und.
Meine Vermutung jetzt, warum aber in England gerade der Lokdown mit der neuen Variante.
Deutlich besser funktioniert als.
Der Logdown bei uns äh mit überwiegend der alten Variante äh muss.
Wahrscheinlich irgendwas mit Compliance äh äh auch zu tun haben, dass die Leute einfach tatsächlich sehr von sich aus ihre Kontak.
Mehr reduzieren oder das vielleicht auch mehr Kontrollen stattfindet. Das ist einfach die Wahrnehmung äh äh die ist ich weiß nicht ob du da irgendwelche,
Erkenntnisse oder Meinungen zu hast, ich hatte nur gehört, dass irgendwie ein fünfzigtausend Strafen ausgesprochen wurden wegen Corona Verstößen. Ich habe jetzt keine Vergleichszahlen für Deutschland.
Gut in Berlin weiß ich nicht, habe ich immer von wären's ein paar hundert oder vielleicht ein paar tausend Strafzettel gewesen sein, die ausgestellt worden sind.
Aber ja aus irgendwelchen Gründen funktioniert der Logdown in UK, äh, der auf dem Papier nicht wesentlich schärfer ist.
Deutlich besser als der Loktown bei uns.
Also auf dem Papier ist,
hab da derzeit keinen Einblick ehrlich gesagt. Also ich hab den Eindruck, dass die da schon härter an der Bremse ziehen derzeit, aber ich weiß es nicht wirklich und das ist vielleicht auch einfach schwierig zu vergleichen
Na gut, jetzt können wir vielleicht diese Debatte an der Stelle äh auch erstmal abschließen, also äh im Großen und Ganzen gut, dass die Zahlen runtergehen, sie gehen nicht schnell genug runter
wenn sich daran nichts ändert, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass wir mit den neuen Varianten uns äh quasi eine eine neue Subpandemie eintreten relativ hoch und dann kann es eben auch sehr gut sein, dass wir dann im April, Mai
feststellen nach Ostern ja mh hat wieder alles nicht gepasst. Jetzt müssen wir schon wieder ganz kräftig die
Bremse anziehen, damit wir hier überhaupt noch irgendwas reißen können, mal ganz abgesehen davon, wie sich dann eben die neuen Varianten auf diese ganze Impfthematik.
Auswirken. Jetzt magst du vielleicht noch kurz zu zu den Berliner äh Zahlen noch was sagen?
Dass wir das komplett haben, bevor wir zum Feedback weitergehen.
Ja, also in Berlin sieht die Situation im Großen und Ganzen genauso aus.
Im Bund die Zahlen sind halt nochmal deutlich eratischer, also insbesondere dann ja also es gibt.
Im siebenten Tagesmittel äh schwanken sie so stark, dass wir in den letzten beiden Wochen jeweils.
Auch so für ein Tag jeweils ein steigendes sieben Tage Mittel hatten, was jetzt nicht sein sollte und.
DR Wert ist jetzt in Berlin auch ein bisschen höher.
Sogar ja tendenziellen Ticken höher als.
Im Bund so äh also ja aber das ja.
Interessant ist ja jetzt eher so die Detail aus Wertung, die du da gemacht hast.
Genau, also.
Einmal so die sieben Tage Inszenz nach Altersgruppen ist ja immer äh so interessant. Auch da haben wir.
Gesehen vor allen Dingen in der Altersgruppe achtzig Plus sind die glücklicherweise sehr stark zurückgegangen.
Aber seit einer Woche.
Verharren, die ungefähr auf selben Niveau während alle anderen Altersgruppen immer noch nach unten äh zeigen deutlich. Der der Trend.
Und ähm.
Am den den stärksten Rückgang äh hatten wir in den letzten zwei Wochen jetzt in der Altersgruppe fünfzehn bis vierunddreißig.
Ja und auch bei.
Schülern also Altersgruppe fünf fünf bis vierzehn.
Haben wir den den Niedrig, die niedrigste Institz und da ist die Institz jetzt schon deutlich unter.
Fünfzig mittlerweile bei den bei den fünf bis vierzehnjährigen in Berlin. Ja, äh, dass.
Keine Schule hil.
Dazu.
Ja, also die geschlossenen Schulen äh muss man sagen, tragen mit Sicherheit äh gerade gut dazu bei, beziehungsweise,
glaube man kann.
Sogar mit Fug und Recht behaupten, dass die geschlossenen Schulen gerade den Unterschied ausmachen zwischen sinkenden und steigenden Zahlen.
So wie an, ich meine, andere Maßnahmen auch, also ich sage mal, alle der wirksamen Maßnahmen.
Wenn man die aufheben würde, äh würden wahrscheinlich diesen Unterschied ausmachen, aber definitiv äh äh gehören Schulen mit dazu.
Ja. Ja, Berlin.
Haben wir auch einen äh auch einen schönen Rückgang, sogar einen deutlich stärkeren Rückgang bei der positiven Quote jetzt, sind wir auf acht Komma vier Prozent sogar runter, wo Berlin.
Äh in im Gipfel äh deutlich höher lag, als als der Bundesdurchschnitt und wir kommen jetzt auch seit längerem mit dem Testen wieder ganz gut mit, also da schipp,
schaffen wir es auch in Berlin alle zu testen die ähm in Berlin krank werden und.
Erfreulicherweise auch deutlicher Rückgang hm.
Bei den Stationären äh Aufnahmen beziehungsweise bei der Gesamtzahl der Patienten, die in Berlin stationär sind, da sind wir ungefähr bei zwölfhundertfünfzig jetzt von.
Ungefähr achtzehnhundert in der in der Spitze und
auf den Intensivstationen geht's nicht ganz so schnell zurück beziehungsweise leider auch in den in Berlin so in der letzten Woche ungefähr gleich,
geblieben, kann man sagen,
Äh ja und die in auf den Berliner Intensivstationen liegen halt auch noch äh so dreihundertfünf über dreihundertfünfzig Leute äh das ist schon,
'ne Menge, ja, mit Beatmung das soweit zu Berlin.
Vielleicht noch einen Blick auf Europa.
Ja, Blick auf Europa, international. Hm.
Ist äh oder fangen wir erstmal ja mit Tschechien an, was äh mal auch eines der interessanten Beispiele sind, die haben.
Jetzt eine dritte Welle gerade hinter sich haben.
Die auf die Hälfte ungefähr nur runtergebracht und setzen jetzt zur vierten Welle,
gerade an, so wie es aussieht, also da äh geht dann nicht mehr wirklich was runter. Hm.
Ja nicht nicht ganz Europa war Israel ähm es war auch die haben ja,
ja jetzt auch die dritte Welle äh hinter sich und da äh sind sie aber nach wie vor auch auf einem extrem hohen Niveau praktisch wie,
Tschechien kann man sagen mit zwar auch hier Zurückgang aber in der letzten Woche auch nicht mehr, also,
Israel, Tschechien, wie gesagt, auf einem sehr hohen Niveau. Spanien ebenfalls in derselben.
Zu Israel. Ähm also da gibt es Berichte, dass äh also diese hohen Institenzen, die sie haben
Also die sind ja bei was sind die siebenhundertachtzig
so in der Größenordnung siebenhundertsiebzig, also wirklich extrem hoch, wenn man jetzt mal das so mit unseren neunzig, die wir jetzt gerade haben vergleichen. Trotz der ganzen Impfkampagne, da sagen wir auch nachher nochmal was dazu. Aber die Zahlen geben jetzt wohl auch her
dass es einfach ein extrem hoher Infektionsrate jetzt unter Jugendlichen gibt,
Und das wird dann halt auch teilweise auch diese neue Variante zurückgeführt. Also da sieht man unter Umständen auch schon die Auswirkungen. Obwohl die Impfkampagne schon gut voranschreitet. Die Jungen sind natürlich nicht geimpft,
ne? Und dementsprechend kann das da auch noch gar keine Auswirkungen haben, aber es zeigt sich, dass eben
neue Variante auch junge Leute noch mehr in Gefahr sind, auch das nochmal so im Hinblick auf die äh Schulöffnungsdebatte, ja, weil wo vorher einfach der Virus vielleicht bei vielen einfach überhaupt nicht durchgekommen ist.
Schafft es einfach die neue Variante jetzt besser. Also kurz gesagt Kinder sind,
Durch die neue Variante gefährdeter sich auch zu infizieren und das eben auch mit den entsprechenden Konsequenzen. Ich sage da auch gleich nochmal was zu dem Feedback äh äh nochmal was dazu.
Ja. Wobei man auch hier klarstellen muss, dass ähm sagen die neuen Varianten.
Für Kinder nicht gefährlicher sind als für Erwachsene. Daran hat sich jetzt nichts geändert, aber sagen im Vergleich alte Variante äh neue Variante ist,
die neue Variante eben bei Kindern mehr
erfolgreicher als die neue Variante bei älteren mehr erfolgreicher ist es bei allen mehr erfolgreicher aber ja äh Kinder kriegen sie wohl schneller und so eben anekdotische.
Berichte,
jetzt von auch ja teilweise Ärzten oder äh Mitarbeitern im englischen äh Gesundheitswesen, die sich die Fälle dann angeguckt haben, haben äh dann gesagt, gut.
Also als das so losging, hatten sie halt plötzlich ganz viele Fälle, wo äh wenn einer in der Familie es hatte, äh hatten's dann alle
praktisch. Das ist halt sehr häufig vorgekommen. Wir haben sich gefragt
wie kommt denn das jetzt, weil vorher wohl die Übertragung in Haushalten sich so eher in Grenzen hielt, aber mit der neuen Variante kannst du sagen, auch wenn dein Kind die neue Variante mit nach Hause bringt
ist die Chance,
im Gegensatz zur alten Variante, dass sich der Rest der Familie nicht ansteckt. Nochmal deutlich geringer. Dazu,
kommen dann eben auch das sehr wahrscheinlich die neue Variante um ungefähr dreißig Prozent tödlicher ist.
Ja ähm.
Und dass man sich dann wahrscheinlich mit einigen, aber da kommen wir noch dran äh mit einigen neuen Varianten auch äh nochmal ein zweites Mal anstecken kann, wenn man Corona schon mal hatte.
Ja ähm also Corona Alt schon mal hatte. Aber ja, international, also ja Spanien.
Auch äh jetzt die dritte Welle.
Nicht durch, aber äh den den Gipfel bei der dritten Welle überschritten.
Du hast den Spitzenreiter vergessen, ne.
Äh äh.
Spitzenreiter ist Portugal. Also Portugal prügelt sich gerade mit einer Institanz von achthundertneunzig rum. Also das,
top sogar nochmal die Situation in äh Israel ist jetzt wohlgemerkt, der Blick auf äh Europa plus Israel. Israel nehmen wir jetzt halt einfach mit rein in diesem Blick äh ähm einfach wegen der Impfkampagne,
so und dann kommen Montenegro, dann kommt Tschechien. Dann kommt Spanien, dann kommt Slowenien äh.
Litauen, nee, Entschuldigung, Littland.
Slowakei, da sind wir jetzt also so ein dreihundertfünfziger Bereich Albanien und so UK steht so bei dreihundertvierzehn fünfzehn mit mit Frankreich zusammen. Also das.
Ja, du bist jetzt bei bei Ourworld in in Data, bei den Werten, ne?
Da muss man dann immer dazu sagen, das ist jetzt nicht die sieben Tage Institanz, sondern das ist der sieben Tagesdurchschnitt pro Million,
Also das ist sozusagen um um auf die sieben Tage Institanz zu kommen äh muss so halt durchziehen äh teilen und
mal mit sieben multiplizieren. Also ist ungefähr, aber es äh ungefähr zwei Drittel, also bis ungefähr ein Drittel äh äh abziehen.
Das mit der sieben um nur.
Okay, die Zahlen des Spiels auch keine Rolle. Ich wollte eigentlich jetzt
eher darauf hinaus wo es derzeit am meisten geschehen so, ne? Und da ist einfach Portugal ganz weit vorne und würde man halt jetzt Israel noch in die europäischen Länder mit reinnehmen, denn das eben auch
im Vergleich dazu stehen wir noch verhältnismäßig gut da. Da sind wir so im unteren Bereich, aber glücklich kann man damit halt auch nicht sagen. So, jetzt.
Ja ähm gut.
USA vielleicht noch, also die USA scheinen seit beiden Präsident äh S.
Na gut, eigentlich ja doch es sind so selten ja doch kann man sagen seitdem fallen dort auch die Zahlen.
Ähm ja natürlich.
Test sozusagen.
Ja weiß nicht ob das wirklich was miteinander zu tun hat.
Ähm wahrscheinlich ist es am ehesten eine Koinzidenz äh aber möglicherweise.
Äh ja hat mehr Vernunft.
Vielleicht auch positive Auswirkungen äh die wir da sehen können. Also sie sind auf jeden Fall auch jetzt äh schon mal bei den bei den Neuinstidenzen.
Zwar auch noch recht hoch bei ungefähr um die dreihundert.
Aber sind halt von siebenhundert glaube ich irgendwas äh runtergegangen jetzt. Ähm.
Ja gut, was haben wir ähm wo lohnt sich's halt noch? Vielleicht hinzugucken. Ja, okay. Nacht auch.
Mit guten Bekämpfungserfolgen von neunhundert auf dreihundertfünfzig sich runtergearbeitet.
Bei uns unsere Kurve sieht irgendwie hässlich aus. Das ist irgendwie nicht äh keine richtigen Peaks im Vergleich. Das ist die ist zackig und eckig und ausgefranst äh trotz ähm.
Ja sieben Tage Glättung äh ja und besser als Deutschland im Moment.
Und sagen Europa äh sitzt halt so Griechenland und Dänemark und Finnland und Norwegen. Und ansonsten ja insgesamt sage ich mal.
Sind wir jetzt in den zwanzig Prozent der der europäischen Länder, würde ich sagen, die das Ganze noch am besten äh hinkriegen, aber.
Nicht gut.
Es ist halt nirgendswo wirklich gut, außer außer in Island.
Was in Ist, ja.
Norwegen und Finnland, ja.
Ideen haben zwar weiter anwachsen lassen, da sind die Zahlen halt schneller hochgegangen, aber die haben dann,
deutlich besser und effizienter bekämpft als wir.
Hätten wir keine Ahnung. So gut und so stark bekämpft wie.
Den ja dann könnten wir jetzt tatsächlich wieder Dinge öffnen. Schaffen wir so.
Äh
Aber machen wir nicht, wir bekämpfen stattdessen lieber nur ein bisschen und freuen uns dann über einen langen äh ausgiebigen Lokdown. Ja.
Okay, lass uns äh weitermachen, dann die Zeit äh rennt uns sonst davon. Ich würde jetzt ganz gerne nochmal kurz aufs Feed
äh eingehen, einerseits äh was für unsere kleinen Clubhaus äh Quatschrunde äh gehabt haben, diese Woche danke für die Wortmeldung dort. Das war wieder ein sehr kreatives äh Gespräch. Wollte nur mal kurz
aufbringen, was dort so aufgebracht wurde.
Weil wir haben ja so ein bisschen äh gefragt so, wozu habt ihr Fragen? Was sind so die Dinge, die euch,
unklar sind. Ein Thema, was aufkamen waren, Schnelltests.
So ein bisschen mit der Frage, warum sind die eigentlich nicht so verfügbar? In dem Bereich hat sich ja auch gerade einiges getan
Grundsätzlich denke ich war die Politik derzeit einfach noch ein bisschen zurückhaltend. Es gab halt ja immer noch keine Schnelltests, die jetzt wirklich für privat
äh Leute empfohlen war, sondern es gab immer noch so diese Einschränkungen, sollte von medizinischem Personal gemacht äh werden. Meiner Auffassung nach lag das daran, dass eben die bisherigen Antigenschnelltests äh so einen Abstrich ähm,
hinteren Nasenraum erforderlich haben gemacht haben, dass.
Wenn man das mal selber macht, ich weiß nicht, hast, also hast du es, hast du schon mal so einen Schnelltest
in der Hand gehabt. Ich habe jetzt die, die ich hatte, war mal endlich mal zum Einsatz äh gebracht, einfach mal so aus äh Interesse und na ja, ist nicht wirklich schwierig,
das zu machen, das einzige Problem ist, es kitzelt halt irgendwie enorm, man muss danach irgendwie und ähm währenddessen im Zweifelsfall auch äh kräftig niesen und ähm
das ist vielleicht so das Hauptproblem äh so richtig eklig und unangenehm empfand ich das jetzt äh äh nicht wirklich. Das kann man schon mal machen, aber mir ist schon klar, warum das jetzt nicht unbedingt so empfohlen wird. Ist
Kunde, das neue Schnelltest kommen sollen, die äh glücklich sind mit einem Abstrich im vorderen Nasenbereich
das wäre schön, wenn die da schon,
ausreichend ähm sensibel sind. Ich habe da noch so ein bisschen meine Zweifel, aber es wird sich zeigen. Also es kann durchaus sein, dass da was kommt.
Firmen meiner Meinung nach,
Business machen sollten und irgendwelche Treffen und sonstige Meetings tun sollten dort zuschlagen. Ähm inwiefern das gemacht wird, keine Ahnung
Dann gab's natürlich viele Fragen rund um die Impfstoffentwicklung
speziell eben die Frage wie erfolgreich werden diese Impfstoffe sein im Hinblick auf dieses gesehen haben, also dass die neuen Motationen
ähm also dass die alten Impfstoffe quasi nicht mehr genauso effizient gegen die neuen Mutationen vorgehen
können. Dazu lässt sich im Prinzip sagen ja das kann so sein
oder das zeichnet sich zumindest jetzt ab in äh ersten Tests,
Bei den Testsiegen gemacht werden, nimmt man halt ähm Serum von Leuten, die eben geimpft worden sind mit den neuen äh Impfstoffen, also.
Blutentnahme und die darin sich befindenden
Antikörper und wendet das dann so Petryschalenmäßig ähm gegen äh das Virus äh an und schaut eben, ob die
entsprechend bekämpft werden können. Dabei ist halt festgestellt worden, dass eben die Immunantwort da nicht mehr so so stark ist.
Aber das ist eben nicht alles, was der Körper macht, also nicht alles, was der Körper entgegensetzen kann,
befindet sich jetzt unbedingt in diesem Serum. Von daher muss man diese Ergebnisse nochmal abwarten, aber es ist halt auch so, diese MRNA.
Impfstoffe können relativ schnell angepasst werden und es gibt jetzt eben diese Diskussion. Moderner hat das aufgebracht,
ob man nicht vielleicht im Notfall dann halt auch noch so eine dritte Dosis macht, dass man eben sagt, okay, wir machen jetzt hier nochmal einen neuen Cocktail, der berücksichtigt sie die neuen Varianten
Das packen wir dann eben in so eine spezielle Dosis, die eben Leuten gegeben wird, die schon die zweite Dosis erhalten haben als so zweiter Boost
dann ja geht das, ne? Dann kam natürlich die Frage auf.
Bedeutet, dass das diese neuen Impfstoffvarianten dann äh auch nochmal diesen ganzen Phase drei Test durchlaufen müssen. Antwort.
Wahrscheinlich nicht, denn äh,
eigentliche Problem bei der Verträglichkeit dieser Impfstoffe ist gar nicht so sehr das, was in dieser MR, in dieser MRNA kodiert ist, was ja die eigentliche Immunantwort äh erzeugt, letztlich,
sondern das Problem ist eben diese Gesamtkomposition, sprich diese Fetthülle, in der das eben eingeschlossen ist mit dem dass äh der Impfstoff in den Körper eindringt und das ist halt alles schon getestet worden,
und ähnlich läuft's ja auch jetzt schon bei der Grippeimpfung
haben wir ja auch jährlich ein Update, da werden jetzt auch nicht immer wieder Phase drei Tests gestartet, sondern es ist halt so ein itterativer Prozess, inwiefern das jetzt schon rechtlich abgesichert ist, kann ich nicht sagen, aber davon kann man halt ausgehen, dass das am Ende nicht das Problem ist
Dann hat sich noch jemand gemeldet, der auch nochmal drauf hingewiesen hat, dass eben,
dieses ganze Problem mit der Infektion von Kindern nicht so auf die leichte Schulter nehmen äh soll, hat äh auf die.
Webseite des DPI verwiesen, das ist die deutsche Gesellschaft für Petriatische Infektion, also,
Gesellschaft, die sich,
speziell eben um Infektionskrankheiten und Kinder ähm kümmert und ähm ja da kommt so die Aussage her, dass wir eben bisher auch schon so tausend Hospitalisierungen gesehen haben von,
Kindern im Rahmen der Pandemie und dass es eben auch zahlreiche Berichte gibt über solche Postkowit äh Vorkommnisse, also.
Stichwort ist da so Kawasaki-Syndrom, dass eben auch Kinder durchaus auch Langzeitfolgen von der Erkrankung nach sich ziehen äh können,
Das war so mal grob zusammengefasst, das was so der Schwerpunkt war. Ansonsten gab's natürlich noch viel kleinere Diskussionen, aber ja, war auf jeden Fall eine schöne Runde.
Im Blog gab's dann auch noch äh Feedback,
wurde dann vor allem darauf hin äh gewiesen, dass ich wieder dummes Zeug erzählt habe. Ich habe gesagt, beim Masernimpfstoff äh sei die,
Effizienz ja auch sehr viel niedriger irgendwie ich hab glaub ich fünfzig oder sechzig Prozent gesagt das ist natürlich Unsinn
Konkret wird hier äh korrigiert, dass die Effizienz des Astrazinica-Impfstoffs mit sechzig Prozent höher wäre, als die das Masernimpfstoff ist Quatsch. Die Effizienz des Masernimpfstoffs liegt bei achtundneunzig bis neunundneunzig Prozent
Ist Dance Corrected. Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht mehr ganz genau, was ich da durcheinander bekommen habe. Ich bezog mich auf.
Auf den Grippeimpfstoff. Okay, gut, das äh kann ich jetzt auch erstmal nur so behaupten, äh dass es mir dann durcheinander geraten, also das war kein gutes Beispiel.
Ja, dann gab's noch viel Diskussion um äh unsere Anmerkung zum Thema Impfstoff
Produktion und warum denn ähm ob's denn wie skandalös sind das nun sei, dass die ganzen ähm Lieferungsankündigungen runtergefahren werden.
Da gab's sehr viele Hinweise auf zahlreiche Artikel, äh auf die ganzen komplexen Maßnahmen, die erforderlich sind, um die Produktion insbesondere der MRNA,
Impfstoffe überhaupt hochzufahren,
Hinweise dadrauf, dass eben hier sehr viel Technik bestellt werden muss, Maschinen bestellt werden müssen, die müssen erstmal gebaut werden, die müssen geliefert werden, die müssen teilweise auch nochmal komplett neu zertifiziert werden.
Das dauert alles, dazu muss Personal eingestellt werden, ausgebildet werden, alles nicht so einfach. Es gab dann auch noch einen schönen Link auf einen längeren Artikel
zu der ganzen Surply Chain von MRNA-Impfstoffen, das werde ich mir nochmal in Ruhe anschauen, vielleicht nächste Woche diskutieren. Kommt aber auf jeden Fall auch nochmal mit in die,
Shownotes,
Das war so im Wesentlichen das, was äh ich an Feedback gesehen habe. Gab natürlich noch viel kleineres äh nebenbei, aber muss sagen, es ist mittlerweile so viel Feedback, dass ich auch schon Schwierigkeiten habe, äh hinterherzukommen.
Vielleicht noch was ich dem noch vielleicht hinzufügen möchte bei,
so
hatten wir dann, glaube ich, auch eine Österreicherin äh äh dabei, die dann darauf aufmerksam gemacht hat, dass offensichtlich die Österreicher ähm irgendwie ähm,
ja, diese Schnelltests seit längerem äh schon für die Eigenanwendung verfügbar,
haben und es offensichtlich nicht zu einem Massenanfall von äh Leuten, den
dass das Ding in der Nase stecken geblieben ist oder die sich versehentlich ins Gehirn gestochen haben oder so. Äh das scheint jetzt kein größeres Problem,
zu sein und ja und.
Klar, wie man irgendwie so einen Corona-Test interpretiert, auch so einen Schnelltest, so ein vor allem ein negatives Ergebnis interpretiert, dass es nochmal eine andere Sache, äh wobei generell ich mein.
Bei äh ja, der Aussagekraft von Tests äh ist, glaube ich, bei manchen Leuten auch ein bisschen Verwirrung da.
So nach dem Motto, wieso, ich bin doch schon äh vor einem halben Jahr negativ auf Korona getestet worden, äh so, wieso bin ich jetzt auf einmal krank oder.
Kann das sein. So oder nee von mir geht keine Gefahr, sie hatte vor einem halben Jahr einen Korona Test. So, der war negativ.
Das gibt es halt eben auch ja aber das.
Problem hat man dann nicht nur bei Schnelltest, sondern auch bei dem normalen Test, dass die Leute, dass äh irgendwie.
Zum Teil zumindest viel interpretieren, was ein negativer Koronatest eigentlich aussah.
Nehme ich eigentlich nur, dass man zu dem Zeitpunkt, als die Probe entnommen wurde, äh noch nicht allzu lange äh infiziert gewesen sein kann.
Oder gar nicht.
Genau.
Deswegen sind regelmäßige Tests halt auch wichtig, wenn man sich wirklich sicher sein will und die andere Methode ist halt einfach äh weg, schließt euch weg, wenn ihr könnt. So wie ich das mache.
Dann gab's noch eine Meldung aus den USA, die fand ich ganz ähm interessant und zwar ist dort ein Schnelltest zugelassen worden aus Australien.
Der jetzt gar nicht so funktioniert, wie das die äh Schnelltests machen, die wir jetzt hier bisher kennengelernt haben,
Bisher sagen wir ja, Schnelltest ist dieser Anti-Gentest, der auf diesem Letteral Flow Verfahren basiert. Das heißt, man hat ähm eine Probe.
Man entnimmt sich das Jahr, dann äh hat man das so am Tupfer, dann dann muss das in so ein kleines ähm
ja in so einem kleinen Plastik äh Behälter reingequetscht werden, wo nochmal so eine Lösungsflüssigkeit drin ist, mit dem sich das dann eben verpaart,
und wenn man diesen Tupfer da schön ausgequetscht hat, tropft man drei,
Tropfen davon dann auf dieses Plasteteil, auf diesen eigentlichen Sensor und dann zieht sozusagen diese ganze Masse durch diesen Streifen hindurch und äh an einer Stelle kriegt man dann halt eine Markierung
für,
das hat auch funktioniert, dass Zeug ist hier wirklich durchgezogen, deswegen erscheint diese Linie und wenn kurz davor nochmal die andere Linie auch noch aufleuchtet, na dann hat man eben auch Corona.
Stellt sich raus, es gibt hier irgendwie mittlerweile auch einen ein digitales Angebot von einer,
australischen Firma mit dem schönen Namen Elum Health und die behaupten ein Cover neunzehn Hometest zu haben,
USA.
Apotheke oder was weiß ich wo
Und das Ding funktioniert tatsächlich äh digital und
ich hab's mir jetzt irgendwie mal durchgelesen, aber es ist irgendwie völlig äh äh absurd. Also erstmal verspricht das Ganze irgendwie auch sechsundneunzig Prozent Genauigkeit äh sehr umso infizierter die Leute sind, umso klarer sind die Aussagen. Und da habe ich mir angeschaut so, aha, okay, das funkt dann irgendwie mit
Bluetooth das Ergebnis auf mein Smartphone und somit App so, ach klingt ja alles schon mal sehr st
ne? Aber das bedeutet ja, ich habe jetzt hier nicht einfach so einen Teststreifen, den ich mit dem Auge ablese, sondern wir reden hier wirklich von einem Digital
ermittelten Ergebnis zu Hause. Dachte ich mir so, aha, wie funktioniert das? Und dann spricht die.
Beschreibung von einem Supercharged Fluoressent im you know cromatography using equantum dotbased flurass it partical.
Wenn ich mal versuche das so ein bisschen Deutsch zu machen, es ist irgendwie,
hochgeladene Flures Center äh Immunchromatographie unter Verbindung äh,
eines Quantenpunktflures Zenspartikels.
Das sagt mir dann auch relativ wenig, ist überhaupt der Begriff Quantenpunkt schon mal über den Weg gelaufen.
Ja ähm im Zusammenhang mit äh Quantencomputing. Das sind im Prinzip.
Einfach ja mikroskopische,
Strukturen, äh die zwar deutlich größer sind als Atome, sich aber im Prinzip,
so ein bisschen verhalten wie einzelne Atome so. Ähm ja, aber,
inwieweit jetzt äh also Quantenpunkte äh also wie groß ich die Punkte mache
so weiß ich nicht, ob das irgendwie eine Auswirkung hat darauf wie stark das Floristiert oder nicht keine Ahnung klingt, aber
wie 'ne ganz schönes Ray an Bassworts und ich,
weiß nicht, also es ja also das klingt für mich dann immer nicht so,
ja Vertrauen erwecken, wenn äh die den Mund so voll nehmen.
Also auf jeden Fall, man nimmt irgendwie eine Probe, macht das da drauf und dann gibt's irgendwie äh auf diesen Quantenpunktlevel, da so eine Flure Sense und äh dieser dieser Hardware, dieses.
Gerät ist offensichtlich dann in der Lage diese Floraszenz in irgendeiner Form so auf Manano-Partikelbasis zur Kenntnis zu nehmen und daraus eine Aussage abzuleiten,
ist es jetzt irgendwie von der FDA äh zugelassen worden in den USA, es wird dann demnächst verkauft, wird zur Anwendung kommen. Keine Ahnung, ob das irgendwas äh äh ändert, aber ich fand's bemerkenswert,
das ist jetzt an dieser Stelle auch tatsächlich so eine Lösung gibt. So, ne? Also es ist äh irgendwie bemerkenswert.
Ja? Also ich gehe mal davon aus, wenn die FDA das geprüft hat, wird's halt funktionieren. So.
Aber ja gut mit aber die Kombination mit Smartphone ist natürlich.
Das ist wirklich strange.
Schon wieder ja.
Also ja gut. Okay, spart vielleicht dann ein Display oder so und äh und irgendwelche Knöpfe mit in das Gerät einzubauen, aber nichtsdestotrotz ja äh.
So ist das heutzutage ohne Cloud, auch keine Pandimiebekämpfung.
Genau, also ja genau am besten noch Internetanschluss nötig, dass wir ja immer nur noch fehlendes sagen ohne Internet, das auch nicht geht.
Geht's auch nicht.
Ja, dann habe ich noch einen Link für euch äh an der Uni Bielefeld äh ist es wohl irgendwie gelungen mit Helium-Ionenmikroskopen,
ähm dieses Corona-Virus zu fotografieren oder zu.
Zu machen. Da gibt's dann äh in dem verlinkten Paper
gibt's äh hübsche Bilder wie all diese ganzen kleinen Corona-Saaskopf zwei Viren aus Zellwänden aus,
also so wo sozusagen eine Zelle die Dinger produziert und die dann so aus dieser Zelle heraustreten, das ist zumindest meine Interpretation dieser Bilder.
Da kann ich jetzt nicht so sehr viel zu sagen, was für ein großartiger Durchbruch das ist, aber ich fand irgendwie die die Fotos ganz hübsch, könnt ihr euch ja selber anschauen.
Ja und dann wie versprochen wollten wir nochmal auf die Situation in Israel äh blicken.
Haben wir ja so ein bisschen die Hoffnung, dass wir da neues lernen ähm in Punkto,
Impfung und deren Wirksamkeit.
Und ich habe mir dann auch vor allem mal, gerade weil ich die Daten auf Hour World and Data so ein bisschen verwirrend fand. Dort wird ja.
So eine so ein Vergleich zwischen den Ländern gemacht, wie viel denn da so verimpft ist und dann wird halt äh Israel derzeit so mit sechsundsechzig Prozent angegeben.
Das Ding ist halt nur, sie zählen einfach, sie zählen nicht wirklich Impfungen, sondern sie zählen halt Dosen. Sprich.
Wenn jemand zweimal geimpft wird, dann zählt es halt dann auch entsprechend doppelt. Also ihre sechsundsechzig Prozent
gehen dann sind quasi von zweihundert Prozent, wenn man's mal äh richtig nimmt und müsste äh im Zweifelsfall halt dann auch nochmal geteilt werden. Aber wir haben ja äh aus der letzten Sendung schon ähm dieses schöne
hybrische Dashboard der israelischen Gesundheitsbehörde und da ist das alles schön aufgeschlüsselt. Ich habe mir das jetzt nochmal rausgesucht.
Also Stand heute sieht es so aus in Israel. Zehn Prozent der Bevölkerung haben ihre zweite Impfung.
Vor zwei Wochen erhalten. Also zehn Prozent sollten jetzt eigentlich.
Mittlerweile den maximalen Schutz, den diese Impfstoffe versprechen, also die MRNA-Impfstoffe versprechen der von Bayern Tech zumindest Bayern Tech Pfeiser. Die sollten den haben.
Also zehn Prozent der Bevölkerung sollte jetzt im Idealfall maximal Immun sein gegen das Virus.
Einundzwanzig Komma fünf Prozent, also ungefähr das doppelte haben bis heute die zweite Impfung erhalten.
Nur dass es ja dann eben noch ein, zwei Wochen dauert bis eben volle äh Immunantwort dann auch erzeugt wird. Und sechsunddreißig Komma acht Prozent haben die erste Impfung erhalten bisher.
Also das ist so diese Größenordnung äh mit denen man auf diese ganzen Ergebnisse schauen sollte.
Trotzdem es deuten sich erste Erfolge äh an. Man,
meint, zu beobachten, dass eben bei diesen Risikogruppen, die ja jetzt ähm,
bevorzugt geimpft wurden, also achtzig plus siebzig plus äh haben wir das letzte Mal die Zahlen ja auch schon mal diskutiert. Das also auch schon die erste Dosis durchaus einen positiven Effekt hat und dass sich eben die Infektionszahlen hier auch deutlich,
senken. Also das ist so erste Analysen und da sind einundfünfzigtausend Leute beobachtet worden, die ihre erste Impfung im Dezember erhalten haben und es scheint sich zu bestätigen
diese fünfundneunzigprozentige Wirksamkeit nach der zweiten Impfung. Es ist halt gerade ein bisschen.
Schwierig, ähm das so richtig rauszulesen aus den gesamten Zahlen, weil wir ja wie vorhin schon berichtet haben, ist auch gerade mit einem extremen Covet-Ausbruch in Israel zu tun haben und du natürlich dann,
auch entsprechend starke Maßnahmen hast, also wenn du einen starken Lokdown hast, dann gehe natürlich dadurch auch die äh Zahlen zurück und deswegen ist es,
bisschen knifflig hier ähm herauszufinden, was denn jetzt sozusagen die Wirkung,
des Impfstoffs ist und was die Wirkung eines Logdowns ist. Aber sie haben sich hier wohl angeschaut.
Die Unterschiede zwischen Städten, die äh wo die eine, wo der eine Teil der Städte früher als andere geimpft wurden. Also wir haben hal,
die Kampagne in der einen Stadt schon begonnen und in der anderen Stadt äh hat es sehr viel später stattgefunden und dann haben sie halt die miteinander verglichen
Das heißt, sie befinden sich alle in derselben pandemischen Gesamtsituation. Nur bei den einen wurde eben schon geimpft und bei den anderen wurde nicht geimpft und deswegen können sie dort diese Vergleiche machen. Also es ist jetzt auch alles noch nichts
äh abschließendes, aber
grundsätzlich man beobachtet wohl das wohl so nur null Komma null ein Prozent der Geimpften sich überhaupt irgendwie wieder neu anstecken, das heißt es kann sogar sein dass diese fünfundneunzig Prozent sogar noch
übertroffen werden.
Ja, also.
Kann zusammenfassen. Der Effekt ist noch subtil zu dem zum momentanen Zeitpunkt ähm weil eben ja.
Die meisten Leute noch nicht ihre zweite Dosis äh erhalten haben oder lange genug hinter sich haben,
in Israel, als dass das jetzt größere Auswirkungen auf die Gesamtzahlen haben könnte. Also so das erklärt so ein bisschen, dass Paradox von
auch das nach wie vor in Israel immer noch viele Leute sterben und hospitalisiert werden und die Zahlen immer noch hoch sind,
äh und wann sagen, dass die Maßnahmen äh also der Logdown in Israel äh wahrscheinlich zehn bis zwanzig Mal mehr dazu beiträgt.
Dass die Zahlen zurückgehen als die die Impfung
bisher. Das sollte sich aber in den nächsten Wochen äh äh dann tatsächlich ändern, kippen. Also wir sollten eigentlich so in spätestens einem Monat
ziemlich deutlich auch einen Rückgang äh sehen von Neuinfektionen und Hospitalisierungen und Sterbezahlen aufgrund des Impfstoffs aber noch
müssen wir eben sehr genau hingucken, um überhaupt 'nen Effekt zu sehen.
Die Bilder sind übrigens schön, hier habe ich mir diese Helium Ionen Mikroskopie äh das sind schon also bisher die klarsten und schärfsten äh Bilder, die ich so vom,
Virus gesehen habe.
Also weil man ja, man sieht zwar jetzt nicht die einzelnen Spikes, soweit geht's nicht aber man kann sie fast erahnen.
So ist glaube ich die die Auflösung und äh ja sieht halt aus wie.
Wie würdest du das beschreiben, äh wie.
Also irgendwie so rund rundliche Dinge, die äh ja auch oben auf der Zellmembran kleben zu äh ganz vielen Dingen wie, ja.
Nicht Schimbel, nee.
Ist nichts, was man jetzt auf seinem Essen sehen möchte, auf jeden Fall, aber ja, ist auf jeden Fall schön koloriert.
Also in groß sieht es halt sieht sieht nicht gesund aus. So.
So, dann wollte ich nochmal auch auf eine andere Sache hinweisen, die ja in dieser ganzen ähm
Impfdebatte so ein bisschen untergeht, nämlich wie sieht's denn eigentlich mit dem Rest der Welt aus? Meine Industrieländer, die
jetzt schön beliefert mit ihrem teuren Impfzeug und haben natürlich auch am meisten Probleme, aber ist ja nicht so, dass es in anderen Ländern keine Probleme gibt oder dass es in anderen Ländern nicht
bekämpft gehört.
Da habe ich jetzt das erste Mal von einer Initiative gehört, die es aber schon lange gibt. Äh namens Kowax und das ist äh eine äh Initiative, also die sogenannte.
Es ist so, so also Initiative um eben neunzehn Impfstoffe in die ganze Welt zu bekommen und das ist so eine ah so ein Zusammenschluss von.
Der sogenannten Coalition for Appedemic Prepaidnis Innovations CP, dem der Gawi, Wexin Elians und der World Hells Organisation. Also es ist so ein bisschen Großkopfwatt und die haben
Ihren ersten Planungsbericht veröffentlicht
wie viele Impfstoffe sie den Gedenken so der Welt insgesamt bereitzustellen
Ja, das ist jetzt sozusagen der erste Schritt, der hier äh veröffentlicht wurde und da lassen sich dann halt so Zahlen ablesen
was sie denn so meinen, wie viel Dosierungen sie denn zwanzig einundzwanzig voraussichtlich in die Welt bekommen könnten.
Ähm und das steigert sich natürlich so äh von Monat zu Monat.
Jetzt blicke ich zwar hier gerade auf die Zahlen, aber äh versage gerade dabei eine Gesamtzahl hier draus zu bilden. Man muss immer kurz hier.
Mal rechnen, was ist denn hier überhaupt die Einheit Million Dosis, also.
Zwei Komma zwei Milliarden Dosen äh sollen das dann äh bis zum Dezember.
Äh sein, die sie sozusagen der Welt bereitstellen. Da ist noch einiges zu tun, aber ich find's gut, dass auch solche Sachen,
stattfinden und dass wir nicht irgendwie immer nur darauf blicken, wie es denn uns hier so geht, sondern dass wir irgendwie auch mal im Blick haben, dass wir letzten Endes die komplette Welt hier impfen müssen, bevor wir hier äh richtig Ruhe bekommen.
Da linke ich auf jeden Fall mal drauf auf die Meldung. Dann äh.
Gab's noch einen Antrag von Astra Seneka von dem Ochswort äh im Stoff in der Schweiz.
Und Swissmedic heißt da die Zulassungsbehörde und die sind irgendwie nicht so überzeugt. Also während die europäische Zulassungsbehörde den Impfstoff ja bereits zugelassen hat,
findet also die Schweiz, das jetzt nicht so geil, was die da so vorgelegt haben. Wir erinnern uns, da gab's ja immer noch so diese etwas merkwürdigen
mit irgendwie erster erste Dosis, zweite Dosis unterschiedlich et cetera und ich hoff's mir jetzt im Detail nicht durchgelesen was die Schweiz hier bemängelt
also Spismadic, was die da konkret bemängelt, aber offensichtlich äh wollen die sich das nochmal genauer erklären lassen von Astra Senecker, finde ich immer ganz interessant. Also EU meint so, ja, passt schon,
meint so, hm, ja, nee. Vielleicht nehmen wir dann doch lieber was anderes.
Und dann gibt's noch Ergebnisse aus Russland, da haben wir uns ja auch lange Zeit gefragt, was es eigentlich hier mit diesem russischen Impfstoff, der wurde ja relativ früh angekündigt und wurde ja äh schon dann auch äh glaube ich im Militär äh verimpft und angeblich ist ja auch Putins Tochter irgendwie damit geimpft worden und was
weiß ich alles, was da alles noch
äh kam. Auf jeden Fall gibt's jetzt ähm die Phase drei Zwischenergebnisse von diesem Sputnik fünf getauften Impfstoff,
der eigentlich Gamm-Kuvitt Wack heißt
Äh in the Landset ist das veröffentlicht worden und es sieht auch ganz gut aus. Wir haben nämlich auch eine einundneunzig Komma sechs Prozent Effektivität nachzuweisen mit diesen Phase drei Studien
Und das sind ja äh gute Zahlen. Also das ist vergleichbar mit den besten Zahlen, die auch Astra Senika behauptet.
Und was hier wohl sich positiv auszuwirken scheint, ist die Tatsache, also auch dieser Impfstoff verwendet a Denovieren.
Und ich glaube, du hast auch letzte Mal oder war das irgendwie in unserer Call-Runde.
Clubhaus. Mhm.
Die Frage gestellt, dass ja, wie ist denn das eigentlich, wenn das jetzt so andere Viren sind, könnte der Körper nicht da auch ähm eine Immunantwort erzeugen.
So, ne?
Mhm.
Der Trick hier bei dem Russischen Impfstoff ist der,
dass sie für die erste und die zweite Dosierung, die in drei Wochen Abstand stattfinden muss, zwei unterschiedliche Adinoviaen nehmen.
Irgendwie ja deno Virus fünf an den Novirus irgendwelche Kennzahlen, keine,
genau kennzeichnet auf jeden Fall, nehmen sie halt unterschiedliche und,
damit umgehen sie sozusagen das Problem, dass eine mögliche.
Immunantwort gegen das Adinovirus selber im in der ersten Dosierung sich dann negativ auf die zweite auswirkt.
Ja
schon nach achtzehn Tagen gibt's hier äh auch schon dreiundsiebzigprozentige Wirksamkeit, also mit der ersten Dosis und sie sehen da auch Teezellen und neutralisierende Antikörper und alles was man da so sehen äh will, funktioniert auch mit
älteren Leuten mit sechzig Plus ziemlich gut.
Es gab auch hier keine schweren Fälle, keine Toten nach einundzwanzig Tagen nach der ersten Dosis achtundneunzig Prozent der Geimpften haben nach zweiundvierzig Tagen,
nach sechs Wochen äh Antikörper nachweisen können und äh ein großer Teil davon auch sechsundneunzig Prozent mit neutralisierenden Antikörpern
Also das sieht alles ganz gut aus,
der Impfstoff kommt natürlich jetzt vor allem erstmal in Russland zum Einsatz und ich glaube, es gibt so diverse Vereinbarungen in anderen Ländern, müsste jetzt nochmal den Wexin Tricker reinschauen, habe ich jetzt nicht gemacht, aber in der EU ist noch kein Zulassungsantrag gestellt worden und es ist auch noch ein bisschen unklar
wann und ob denn das überhaupt passiert
auch wenn wohl es Kontakte gibt mit 'nem Pharmaunternehmen in Sachsen-Anhalt diesen Impfstoff gegebenenfalls auch in Deutschland zu produzieren.
Ja
Ja klingt ganz ganz gut, also.
Ich hatte da eben äh noch vielleicht als interessante Informationen. Ich hatte dem halt auch äh gesagt, nachrecherchiert, wie sieht denn das mit,
sagen.
Gegen den Impfstoff aus, wegen der äh Adeno äh Viren und äh ja das Interessante ist, dass sie halt für den.
Sputnik, Human Adinovieren genommen haben, zwei verschiedene,
ähm während so Astra Sinnika äh halt stattdessen ein Schimpansen-Adino-Virus äh nimmt und.
Letztlich muss man offensichtlich zwei verschiedene Dinge, denke ich mal, im im Auge behalten, einmal das durch die Gabe des Impfstoffes äh sich des Immunsystem gegen den Impfstoff,
Selbstsensibilisiert und sozusagen weitere Impfungen mit demselben Adenovirus dann weniger wirksam äh werden
die andere Sache ist bei der Verwendung halt von Humanovieren ist es so, dass so ich glaube etwa achtzig Prozent der Bevölkerung gegen die meisten Adenovieren bereits
Antikörper im Blut haben, das heißt das sein könnte, wenn du sagen schon mal mit demselben Adenovirus infiziert worden bist, den der Impfstoff verwendet, dass der dann
auch nicht so effektiv äh sein könnte. Auf der anderen Seite haben wir halt Adinovieren auch.
Gewisse Maßnahmen produzieren selber bestimmte Proteine, um das Immunsystem äh zu umgehen und das nutzt man wohl teilweise auch
auch aus, um da die Immunantwort äh zu reduzieren, aber ja das ist halt äh.
Sagenden Problem, was man hoffentlich äh bei den Lipiden.
Nicht so sehr hat, wobei,
das Immunsystem halt gegen alle möglichen Stoffe irgendwie sich sensibilisieren kann. Also ich würde es jetzt auch nicht völlig ausschließen.
Und ich meine, wir haben ja wir kennen's ja von Allergikern äh zum Beispiel äh also dass die allergischen Reaktionen so von Leuten.
Hauptsächlich stammen die halt sich eben sehr schnell gegen alles mögliche Körperfremde,
Ja, Antikörper bilden, obwohl es vielleicht nicht nötig wäre und ähm.
Das ist sozusagen das eine Problem, aber ich das kann auch sein, dass das eben bei ganz normalen, gesunden Menschen.
Sagen wie diese Virusvektorimpfstoffe ein bisschen problematischer sein könnten und.
Es ist halt auch so reicht noch, dass ähm.
Jetzt an molekularen Schritten bei den Vektorimpfstoffen halt ein bisschen mehr passieren muss. Die sind halt etwas indirekter. Da muss das Virus halt äh dann erstmal rein und,
im Gegensatz zu den RNA-Impfstoffen ähm passiert.
Bei den äh Vektorimpfstoffen, die Viren verwenden, ähm,
muss halt die molekulare Maschinerie ein bisschen mehr machen, weil äh das Virus muss halt sagen auch eindringen, okay, das ist selber, aber,
beim RNA-Impfstoff kannst dann sofort losgehen, weil in dem Moment, wo die Arena A austritt
kann die dann gleich schon ja von von der Zelle genutzt werden und die Produktion dieser Spike-Proteine.
Läuft halt sofort an während bei den Adino-Viren Vektoren äh.
Die ganze Information als DNA vorliegt und da erstmal dann der Virus selber halt auch erstmal aus DNA, RNA machen muss, bevor.
Die die Zelle, die entsprechenden Proteine produziert und was auch vielleicht noch interessant ist, äh, bei den Spike Proteinen, weshalb man nicht.
Eins zu eins des äh äh Erbgut vom Corona Virus für die Spikes nimmt, ist, dass man.
Sagen unten an der Basis am Ende, wo normalerweise.
Dieses Bikes auf der Virushülle sitzen, ja gar keine Hülle da ist und sich das dann eventuell anders falten könnte, das heißt, da packt man dann quasi noch so ein äh,
stopfen drauf auf den Spike äh unten äh damit,
der auch äh so aussieht wie der Spike, der halt auf auf einer Proteinhülle sitzt.
Das hatten wir äh vor ein paar Sendungen schon mal besprochen, als ich zu
ganzen Geschichte was erzählt habe, wie sich das so entwickelt hat, dass es ja diese äh Entdeckung von dem einen chinesischen Forscher, der dann letzten Endes moderner zugearbeitet hat, diese Grunderkenntnis, welche
Änderungen an dem Proteinmandat vornehmen muss, damit das Spike sich halt auch ohne die Zelle unten ohne den Virus unten dran genauso faltet, als wäre es dran, ne,
Ja, also um's nochmal kurz äh zusammenzufassen. Russischer äh Impfstoff scheint auf jeden Fall auch zu wirken
Verfügbarkeit in der EU unklar, könnte vielleicht unter Umständen irgendwann mal sein, ist für uns jetzt demnächst auf keine Option, aber es kommt auf jeden Fall hier eine äh ja ein weiterer Impfstoff in die Welt
der das ganze Problem zusätzlich in den Griff kriegen kann. Und aus der.
Meldung vielleicht nochmal selber heraus. Ähm, hab dann so 'ne schöne kleine Tabelle noch gesehen in so einem Tweet der das kommentiert hat.
Triales, die jetzt gelaufen sind von sowohl moderner Fiser als auch Novawax, das ist ja auch noch nicht hier zugelassen. Astra Senika und Johnson und Johnson und das geht jetzt im Prinzip
auch nochmal für diesen russischen Impfstoff. Bei allen Teilnehmern aus allen Phase drei ähm Tests.
Gab es keine starken Fälle.
Niemand, der sozusagen mit diesen Impfstoffen geimpft wurde, musste ins Krankenhaus. Keiner, der Impfstoffen geimpft wurde, ist gestorben, ja?
Und dementsprechend ist auch niemand von dem Impfstoff selber krank geworden. Also alles sehr effizient und alles sehr sicher.
Und das über eine Teilnehmerzahl von, wenn ich das mal hier grob zusammen äh rechne, kommen wir sogar noch fast noch zu kleinen äh,
vor hier die Zahlen, das waren sogar noch ein paar mehr, aber ich würde mal so grob sagen, irgendwas zwischen achtzig und hunderttausend Leute
die ähm insgesamt da äh in diesen Triiles unterwegs waren und das sind irgendwie alles sehr ermutigende Zahlen. Also die Impfstoffe sind,
das geringste Problem. Jetzt müssen wir nur noch genug davon,
produzieren und wir müssen sehen, genug Arme bekommen und es müssen vor allem genug Leute bereit sein, sich auch impfen zu lassen, wie sich das so entwickelt, das müssen wir nochmal abwarten.
Ja und bei der Wahl die Frage auch immer wieder aufkommt und wir haben das.
Ja schon mehrfach ähm beantwortet und die Frage soll man sich denn jetzt, wenn man zum Beispiel ein Angebot für das Astra Sinnika.
Für den Astra Senika im Stoff bekommt, sich damit impfen zu lassen, soll man den jetzt äh trotzdem nehmen, obwohl jetzt der Bayerntech Pfeiser äh äh.
Wirkstoff besser zu sein scheint und,
ist meine Meinung und ich glaube deine auch, äh dass äh ja ich mich mit jedem der zugelassenen Impfstoffe impfen lassen würde, weil alle zugelassenen Impfstoffe sind.
Wirksam und sicher. So und äh ja.
Schützen alle vor Tod und schweren Verläufen.
Und äh in insofern ja ähm.
Mach das mal. Wenn ihr, wenn ihr sozusagen die Gelegenheit habt.
Hauptsache impfen.
So, zum Schluss noch äh zwei Kleinigkeiten und zwar war letztes Mal auch schon vergessen, hatten daraufhin zu weisen. Es gab ja neue Versionen der Korona Warnapp.
Und weitere werden auch noch folgen. Also es wird ja weiterhin daran äh gearbeitet. Ich habe jetzt so ein bisschen ausm.
Blick verfolgt, wie siehst du die Installationszahlen entwickelt haben, das äh zeigt einem leider die App auch nicht an, aber was ihr jetzt mittlerweile tut, ist, dass sie zumindest mal so Statistiken macht. Das hatten wir hier auch schon
oft diskutiert und gefordert, dass doch mal bitte diese RKI-Zahlen hier einfach mal visualisiert werden,
Das werden sie jetzt, also es gibt äh so ein Panel äh bestätigte Neuinfektionen. Gut, das ist so ein.
Absoluter Wert, der jetzt nicht äh wirklich so eine Insidenz wieder gibt, ne, sondern es ist sozusagen so ein absoluter äh Wert, aber immerhin und man sieht, ob die, ob der sieben Tage Mittelwert fällt oder steigt, das ist schon mal was,
es gibt auch noch 'ne Information darüber wie viele Leute jetzt mit der Corona Warn App warnen ja? Und wie sich diese Zahlen entwickeln.
Oh, ich habe gedogen, die sieben Tage Institanz wird hier auch wiedergegeben und der sieben Tage Airwert auch
da kann man jetzt über die konkrete Zahl nochmal streiten, das sind halt diese RKI-Zahlen, die unserer Meinung nach ja immer ein bisschen niedriger sind, als sie eigentlich sein sollten
Aber das finde ich auf jeden Fall schon mal ein guten Move. Vorher ist ja auch schon diese Fähigkeit mit dem Kontakttagebuch mit dazu gekommen
das genutzt wird, kann ich nicht sagen. Auf jeden Fall hat man diese Funktionalität.
Und was auch noch kommen wird demnächst. Äh ich glaube, warte mal, ich hatte, glaube ich, sogar schon ein Datum, genau der am zehnten Februar. Also was haben wir heute den fünften? Also in der nächsten Woche wird's ein neues Release geben
und dann werden auch die alten iPhones unterstützt, also wer so noch so ein iPhone sechs oder sechs plus hat, ähm,
ist nicht sogar auch das fünf S. Äh also alles was mit iOS zwölf fünf läuft, dieses Update, was wir neulich mal diskutiert haben, was ja schon äh längst releast wurde
Dann gibt's auch noch die Chrona Warnapp dazu, die dann eben auch diesen alten Telefon noch funktioniert und dann ist das Problem auch gelöst.
Und was auch noch kommt, sind noch die Warnhunde. Das hatten wir, glaube ich, hier vor ein, zwei Monaten mal das das,
in in Finnland zum Einsatz kommt und es gab ja auch so eine Polizeistaffel in Deutschland, wo das auch schon getestet wurde. Jetzt werden die wohl zumindest in Niedersachsen demnächst auch mal wirklich eingesetzt. Ich weiß nicht, warum das jetzt so lange äh gedauert hat.
Aber die sollen wohl dann auch am Flughafen eingesetzt werden. Ist ja überhaupt so äh lustig, dass man sich so denkt so, ja, wie kann denn ein Hund jetzt ein Virus äh riechen,
Das tun die ja nicht. Also die riechen ja nicht das Virus als solches, aber das Virus.
Führt eben dazu, dass in dem Moment, wo es in so einem Menschen aktiv wird, dass eben sich der Körper dadurch verändert. Also die angegriffenen Zellen das führt dann eben dazu, dass hier.
Riechbare Dinge freigegeben werden, die eben Hunde mit ihrer feinen Nase wunderbar auseinanderhalten können. Und das gibt's dann demnächst auch in Niedersachsen.
Corona Warnhunde.
Das bringt uns ans Ende der Sendung Pavel. Jetzt ist wieder äh der Zeitpunkt gekommen, wo du deinen positiven Ausblick auspacken mus.
Jetzt streng dich mal an.
Ja okay, ja noch sinken die Zahlen. Das ist schon mal im Moment jedenfalls erfreulich.
Und bei den Impfstoffen ja ist zumindest ist irgendwie.
Ähm Licht am Ende des Tunnels zu erahnen, äh auch nicht wirklich zu sehen, aber äh so ähm ja wir haben.
Zumindest irgendwie erste Schilder, die darauf hindeuten, dass der Tunnel irgendwann auch einen Ende haben könnte.
Aber ähm ja es kämpfen jetzt zwei Kräfte einfach gegeneinander, einmal unsere nachlassenden Kräfte.
Ähm.
Weiter vorsichtig zu sein äh und äh der der Logdown auf der einen Seite und auf der anderen Seite eben die Mutationen und äh die.
Immer aggressiver und teilweise auch gerade gefährlicher werdenden Virusvarianten.
Wobei normalerweise äh auch sagen,
neue Varianten des Virus eigentlich nicht gefährlicher sein sollten ähm jedenfalls in in ihrer äh Summe nicht ähm insofern,
frage ich mich, ob's da nicht auch noch jetzt Varianten äh gibt, die vielleicht harmloser sind und sich gerade verbreiten.
Die, die wir jetzt sehen können und die geträgt werden gerade äh scheinen nicht harmloser zu sein, sondern im im Gegenteil, ja. Aber.
Auch wieder soll ja positiv bleiben auch die neuen Virusvarianten lassen sich durch Lockdowns bekämpfen,
wie man in England sehen kann. So, also ja und in in Dänemark, äh genau.
Und ich fürchte aber dass wir äh sie auch nochmal aktiv bekämpfen werden müssen und ja ähm im Moment
äh sieht so aus, als wenn wir auf eine.
Dritte, größere Welle äh hinsteuern und neue Logdowns im April und Mai. Aber.
Dazwischen werden wir uns dann irgendwie in ein paar Wochen,
entspanntere äh gefühlt entspanntere Situationen haben und genau die äh wird es auch sein, die dann die Zahlen wieder nach oben treibt, diese gefühlte äh Entspannung bei vielen, nicht bei allen.
Man auch ja kriege ich auch immer mit aus Diskussionen auf Twitter ist gro der Leute.
Einfach äh geht nicht raus wegen dem Virus und nicht wegen der Maßnahmen.
Und ja und die werden natürlich aber auch äh mit sinkenden Zahlen dann ein Teil zumindest dann unvorsichtiger werden.
Die ganzen plus das Drittel äh das halt sowieso nur unter äh Drohung äh mit.
Einem Übel immer bereit ist, sich äh an Maßnahmen zu halten oder bei Schlicht.
Die Möglichkeiten des Virus zu verbreiten von Amtswegen geschlossen sind sowie Kneipen oder andere Dinge.
Ich würde mir auf jeden Fall wünschen, dass die äh äh durchschnittliche Institenz unter UKW-Hörerinnen und Hörern äh deutlich unter dem Durchschnitt liegt,
weil ihr seid ja alle so klug und aufgeklärt und ich hoffe wir haben ein bisschen dazu beigetragen, dass das auch weiterhin der Fall ist. Ja, ansonsten, wenn ihr Lust habt, wir machen wieder unsere,
Clubhausrunde dann am nächsten Dienstag wieder.
Das ist dann der lass mich kurz nachrechnen, der neunte Februar. Wir tragen das Feedback natürlich dann hier auch wieder.
In die Sendung mit rein. Jetzt bleibt uns nur noch uns zu verabschieden. Wir sagen tschüss.
Tschüs.